[Music]
celebrity couples are enjoying the
ultimate date night at the 94th annual
academy awards hitting the red carpet on
hollywood's biggest night in love and in
style we have to start off with kourtney
kardashian and travis barker making
courtney the first kardashian to attend
the oscars this also marks the couple's
first red carpet they've walked together
since getting engaged in october they
perfectly coordinated in black with
courtney wearing a vintage mugler t-link
dress and travis opting for an all-black
suit in typical travis style they even
display some pda sharing a smooch before
heading into the dolby theater belfast
star jamie dornis stepped out looking
dapper as always with his wife amelia
warner by his side who lit up the red
carpet in this long sleeve gold gown
with floral detailing another hot
hollywood couple keith urban and nicole
kidman nicole is wearing a custom
georgia armani pre-based silk gown
featuring a peplum skirt paired with
harry winston julie's can we give them
an oscar for best couple they deserve it
fellow country superstar reba mcintyre
arrived in dolce gabbana alongside her
boyfriend rex lin meanwhile amy schumer
and her husband chris fisher posed for
the camera before amy will take the
stage to co-host hollywood's biggest
night now let's turn our attention to
will smith and jada pickens smith
looking perfectly put together as always
jada proudly stands beside her oscar
nominee husband in the stunning deep
emerald green gown featuring a massive
train absolutely gorgeous jesse clements
and kirsten dunst are hoping that the
power of the dog picks up some awards
tonight having received 12 nominations
the most of any films this year kirsten
glowed in this gorgeous ruffle red dress
with matching heels while jessie rocked
an all black tux and bow tie nominee
kristen stewart brought along her
fiancee dylan myron shared a sweet kiss
on the carpet and we cannot forget
ashton kutcher mila kunis mila showed
off her stunning figure in a rose satin
dre belted gown featuring an
asymmetrical neckline